if I had a thing to plug into my cat's
brains so they could talk to me all they
would say is feed me
hey reject nation Greg Alba here John
hump so a couple of things we wanted to
mention before we go into this dog man
but David Firth reaction here what we
are going to Mexico from August 23rd
through the 25th courtesy of Warner
Brothers so if there's anything big that
drops and we don't cover it that is why
secondly one of our reward tiers in
patreon is whatever video you request we
must definitely cover and today comes
from a man named Nathan Wilton who's
from Wall Street yeah and Nathan we
actually talked to this guy many months
ago he was one of our probably our
earliest patrons and then he kind of
went away I don't know why he was dead
to us your month [ __ ] I don't know what
your problem is I would never say it to
his face he is far too good looking at
he owned that now he's back in our lives
and then he has this request right here
dog of man already back and already
making demands I mean if anyone's a dog
of man it's this guy you know this dog
is slam [ __ ] left and right serial
killer I'm not talking that is getting
ladies killing women someone needs to
stop this guy as soon as possible what's
the number for the police in Australia
is it like nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine one one one two bad the cops don't
have guns
oh me more David first this year than
ever
we both did we both got it wrong
completely wrong
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
the Impala true friend is your own Shiva
I don't spend it all of our place she's
got a giant I always grow in this humor
yeah
[Music]
you may not
[Music]
[Music]
whoa that's a good knife it is a great
knife yeah even taking a life hacking
Oh Oh No
how do you do it how it comes out
together lick it
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
I get it it's Darren Aronofsky's the
Bible yeah it's all very create in the
Bible the whole time allegory of
creation okay locust toy box all right
all right so the dog man's best friend
right here we go Greg attempting to
interpret something yeah his work is not
open to interpretation there's only one
clear definitive anything he does okay
let's let's figure this out John dog
man's best friend says he needs a tumor
to have a real friend and in the process
he is now bonded permanently with his
best friend because they have become one
tumors when someone develops one causes
people that you love to come and seek
your attention so you can bond with them
before they die tumors are good that's
what he's saying I think I nailed it
nailed it on I feel so enlightened
what's your interpretation John I just I
have a very clear and solid
interpretation I am sure I don't know I
mean part of me started to wonder if it
was maybe some kind of weird messed-up
allegory about marketing or something
we're like they're trying to sell you
these things that are really awful for
you and they're pretty obviously awful
for you but you know that rhetoric of
like you'd have a friend if you had your
own tumor so I don't know this was one
of the more obtuse see the last one we
watched I went back and looked at it and
I really got what we missed because I
think we were talking over like one
moment and I was like oh yeah that makes
it very clear this at least doesn't
right now I do very clear reader or it
could just be that humans are not
reliable as best friends but dogs are
easily Nan's best friend and they are
they're disloyal to you maybe it's about
how you shouldn't listen to your dog the
way you would your best friend if your
dog could communicate
you because then it's gonna persuade you
to throw a bunch of tumors inside
yourself and then become some kind of
chimera hybrid yeah it could be about
that dogs really don't have the best
intentions for you that they're really
selfish yeah it could be and they just
want you all to themselves some dogs are
evil yeah this is what David first
believes when I got that plant with all
the happy little growths on it you know
and he wants to be just like the plant
with all the happy look well let's look
at this from a realistic perspective how
did he have this invention that can make
the dog talk where would they get tumor
scenes how did he just rip open his skin
like nothing why didn't no one say
anything when he just stole the seeds
how come he's shirtless everywhere he
goes
this is confident how did he chop off
the dog into pieces then chop off his
own head and surgically attached himself
to the dog's body when his own head was
already cut off these are the real
questions maybe maybe this has no
meaning and just weird and random and
made for a great 2008 creepy ass YouTube
video I think it could be the case yeah
there's others up next right here dog a
man explained oh we're definitely not
gonna watch that and steal anything from
them maybe this is just about being an
individual and never listening to anyone
around you especially the dog who you
have to communicate with by plugging a
plug into his head so that he spits out
of loud speaker yeah I don't know it
could be some kind of weird
you're being impressionable analogy
granted the videos ten years old but
maybe it's about how haze against Trump
being president oh yeah yeah I mean I do
just have a general soft spot for things
like this that are confidently strange
and confidently obtuse because like you
know this is a piece it's only four
minutes and it's really strange and
really kind of creepy and unsettling and
you know I I just appreciate it on that
see the thing is like the cream video
looking back at that and even at the
time I was like okay I get it there's
something at work beneath the surface of
business I'm sure there's something at
work beneath the surface of this too but
oddly I feel even further away from it
held it at a further arm's distance in
this video how you doing with your cat
hair there's so much she gets some cat
hair seeds you can just grow it all over
yourself maybe a dog always needs to
rely on his owner to be fed so if he
becomes one with the owner he can
constantly feed himself hence he doesn't
need the owner anymore or maybe by being
complacent and taking all of your life
advisors from all the people around you
you become like a Frankenstein a hybrid
of yourself and the people around you
yeah we're done throwing things we're
done thanks David first
happy birthday Nathan Wilton you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification pal
juice out patreon where we know so much
and goodbye